mauricio Broly author of niccolo's I did
it wrong
no I did it right giggling Israel yeah
what does it mean when someone says a
politician is Machiavellian when someone
says that the politician is
Machiavellian what they mean to say is
that the person in question has very low
moral standards that the person is not
reliable that he is cunning like a fox
astute that you cannot trust him but
that is what they mean when they say
that the politician is Machiavellian why
did I say that where does it come from
it came from the mid of the 16th century
in within the context of the
counter-reformation then at that time
the Jesuits began to use the word
Machiavellian in the sense that I have
described meaning someone unreliable
someone who always wears a mask someone
who is ready to deceive who is always
keen always ready and prepared to put
his interest before any other moral
consideration was Machiavelli himself
like that
niccolò machiavelli was the opposite of
a Machiavellian precisely the opposite
Machiavelli ins our calculators Nicola
was passionate Machiavelli ins always
try to adapt themselves to the
circumstances like every fought many
battles against the conventional
political culture of his time
Machiavelli ins normally win
Niccolo was a loser makea variance
always fight for what they think they
can get nicola always fought for grand
ideas
he was precise in the opposite then why
over the years does it mean the opposite
of when you say someone's Machiavellian
the opposite of the man that they took
the philosophy from because niccolò
machiavelli works have been read over
the centuries by scholars who were not
apt to understand did not want to make
the effort to understand what nicola was
saying either because they were
prejudiced or because were two bigoted
or for one reason and the other
when did he live he was born in 1469 in
Florence when did he die he he died in
1527 jus which made him how old when he
died I'm very bad with numbers at 58 at
night yeah mo we have 59 I guess but I'm
very bad with numbers or should be 31
plus 27 50 80s even though in one of his
last letters he say now that I am 60 was
not true he was only 58 were me he was
also very bad with numbers where was he
from he was born in Florence yes and the
family was coming from the south and
part of Tuscany he was the son of a
lawyer his father was a lawyer I was
successful which is very rare poor which
is even more difficult because in
Florence lawyers then and even today are
normally very wealthy so Nicola did not
belong to the inner circle
of the Florentine elite he was called he
had the chance to study in new Latin
rhetoric ancient history modern history
grammar he knew how to write well it
shows but he had he did not belong to
the important families for him was
impossible even to be elected or
appointed to important positions in the
government because according to the
statutes of Florence in order to be
appointed to the highest positions you
you had to belong to a family that had
already had someone covering I posts in
the government
that's important because Micheli was
closed to power but never within the
circle of power where are you from I
come from Romania is a bit north of
Florence Roman is the area of Ravenna
Remini Forli if you have seen the
Fellini's movie I'm are called that's
where I came from
how did you get to the United States it
was it was a joke I I had completed my
PhD thesis at European University Flores
I was like many other people at the time
jobless
unemployed I had no chances to get into
an Italian University or year 1980 1985
you are talking a friend of mine a
friend of mine was here I attained
stitute for Advanced Study in Princeton
she said Mauricio they are looking for
an assistant professor in political
theory and I responded to that and do
you think that it Princeton they need
someone from early in Roman
from Italy to cover a position in
political yes it costs you nothing to
try I applied I sent my Vita
my dissertation that I composed then in
French but was in part translated into
English by Cambridge University Press
and I shall never forget the fact that I
got the position at Princeton University
without even knowing the names of the
people is in the committee one day I
must tell the names of these people
because they are an example of you
should conduct this kind of activities
if you want to keep a university great
but how are they on what basis did they
choose you it's the normal application
as you know there were about 250
applicants they selected three I was
what he called the shortlist then they
summoned me I got a phone call late in
the night from Professor Amy Gutmann who
is now the director of the Center for
human values in Princeton she said we
would like to interview you and I asked
back but I have to fly and she said no
problem so I flew over I spent three
days I gave my talk I met everyone in
the department strange feeling very
completely different world then I came
back and after two months I got the
phone call saying we would like to offer
you a position as an assistant professor
in politics that's that is as simple as
that at Princeton at prints and how long
have you taught there since 1987 teach
what political theory and when did you
first start writing about mark Mackay
overhead it's a long it's an old and
deep love for Nicola market I started
writing on niccolò machiavelli in 1980
in 1989 why they title of this book
makes it
smile well because I have written a
number of essays and the book on Nicola
Michaelis political thought then while I
was writing the book on the colour
Machiavelli's political thought I
discovered that perhaps Nicola the
person his life his passions his ideals
was more interesting than the thing and
what was interesting about Nicola his
wisdom of life the wisdom with which he
conducted his life the wisdom with which
he tried to make sense of his own
experience and of human experience in
general meaning how to deal with despair
hopelessness defeat ingratitude but also
with love friendship the various
dimensions of life I have discovered if
I'm right then Nicola conducted his life
he dealt with all the issues that I've
mentioned all the aspects of human
experience that I have mentioned with a
remarkable depth and intelligence wisdom
that wisdom was so to speak summarized
by his smile his way of smiling at life
at himself and who knows perhaps even
smiling at God
where does this portrait come from it's
on the career but it's Tito Santi Sol TD
Tito is his correct name he painted the
pole
or trade after Machiavelli's death so he
did not seem accurate that's how he
imagined Nicola Miguel to be on the
basis of existing sketches or statues
there is a marble sorry wooden bust of
Niccolo Machiavelli in Palazzo Vecchio
where of course I always go to pay my
tribute in the pilgrimage
what is Pilate oh thank you yes second
floor what is it
Palazzo Vecchio is the palace in which
the Great Council of the Republic of
Florence used to meet is in Piazza della
Signoria
is the center of the Republican power of
the Republic of Florence in fact when
Mackay rarely tried to persuade the
Medici in 1521 to restore Republican
institutions in Florence the manner in
which he said that was Rio pre-op
Rotella sala reopen the main hall in
Palazzo a classic is the symbol of
Florence self-government
what is the merging the Medici is the
Medici where the most powerful family in
Florence they were buying kurz silk
traders they had only Machiavelli's
lifetime two popes imagine a family that
can produce two popes he's much more
than producing two presidents of the
United States like the Bush family they
are they were extremely wealthy and
thanks to their wealth they were able to
offer favors lending money helping
people in various ways to set up their
business
or help them to find the solution or
legal problems in this way they became
they became extremely powerful
they had a large network of partisans
supporters so in fact they were
practically the rulers of Florence the
masters of Florence particularly between
1434 and 1464 under the leadership of
Cosimo de Medici then the Medici were
expelled from Florence in 1494 when a
Republican governor was instituted very
turned in power in 1512 with the help of
Spanish armies and they were so to speak
the enemies of the Republic Florence
lived its own political life than the
oscillation between Republican
governments more or less aristocratic
and the regime of the Medici you talk
about the Republic of Florence and a lot
of other Republic's that you mentioned
in your book what was Italy in the early
1500s what did it amount to
well you have to consider that you had
northern part of Italy you had the
Dukedom of Milan that was under was a
dukedom then is the Republic of Florence
Venice sorry they're very powerful very
wealthy very aristocratic south you had
small principalities in bologna Rubino
you had the republic of genoa and then
south you had the Republic of Florence
Florence was not just the city Republic
Florence also controlled a large
countryside did the Republic of Florence
have to answer to anybody else to be
Republic means to be as dead as the
jurists used to say to be see between
ships which means you are you are your
own Prince or you are Prince onto
yourself and you do not recognize
superior powers that is the meaning of
being Republic means that there are you
do not recognize political powers how
many people lived in that part of the
world back in the 16th century in Flores
the seat that whole area you know though
Italy it's difficult to give figures I
know for Florence at the time of
Machiavelli Flores must have been around
sixty thousand people so the whole areas
rather to be small but yes they got a
small population you say and the authors
note and I'll just read it say the
reader will find some fairly strong
language in the letters by Machiavelli
in his correspondence and in documents
of the period expressions that other
biographers have edited or cut and I
must admit to you that I was surprised
that some of the language that was used
back then the four-letter words a lot of
the F word used in those days where does
all that come from interestingly as you
have perhaps noticed the correspondence
and the Friends of Machiavelli use that
kind of language more than Nicola
himself let me give you an example he
one of the best friends of Nicolo
Machiavelli was Francesco Latorre they
had more or less the same age with the
difference that I'm giving you a little
background that Francesco Vettori was
powerful and successful
Niccolo Machiavelli was powerless and
unsuccessful
nonetheless they remained friends when
Vettori was the ambassador of Florence
in Rome
in the at the paper court Vettori wrote
his friend Nicola who was at the time in
Florence elected in which with Tory says
I'm so bored by life here that I must
necessarily think about something
pleasant and I know nothing that is more
pleasant than you know what I mean or
the thought of interesting materially
Nicola responds back with the Latin
which he speaks or the enchanting
sweetness of love someone is using a
friend he'll use that language F so on
Nico responds with a poem on the beauty
and sweetness of the passion of love
nonetheless
Nicola himself was famous in Florence
while his stories he used to tell and
I'm sure that he was pretty good at
using the same language you asked why
because they were Florentine in Florence
there is the air the atmosphere itself
is irreverent
they are colorful there are various ways
of expressing a concept that they always
prefer the most colorful and the most
colorful is exactly the language that I
have described but you decided for some
reason to leave it in the language and
why did most biographers take it out
because I think most biographers well
they thought that perhaps was a bit
damaging to show how they were speaking
I think that in fact there is nothing
wrong in showing contemporary readers
how sixteen
today foreign time are speaking and it's
office also funny because I must say
that you can use colorful words without
being vulgar and you can be vulgar
without using colorful words when you
use words that I like the ones we are
alluding to you must be very good
because then it takes a special
intelligence sensitivity you have to use
them with in the right moment in the
right context and you can see that there
are letters in which if you replace the
colorful words with ordinary words the
letter or the expression would lose its
brightness its intensity remember that
niccolò machiavelli and many other many
friends of him
they were belonging to popular classes
to the people that's where the way that
was the way in which they spoke one of
those story you're going to reveal too
much no I'm not gonna read this as you
all know it's on page 109 it's the old
board 109 yeah you know it's it's it's
Machiavelli oh oh no please don't do
that but well if you want if you read it
now I'm not gonna read it
but I did I bring it up because I want
to ask you I want to ask you the
circumstances of that as a way of
showing what Machiavelli was like
personally is that is that a true story
no I think that this is you big an
important place I think that Nicola like
to make fun of himself he liked to
exaggerate not his virtuous his vices
and in this case what is doing is to
respond they are referring to the famous
letter in which he narrates the
misadventure he had with it an old
prostitute very old very ugly prostitute
in Verona that's what you're mentioned
well you have to consider that
Machiavelli in that letter is responding
to a letter of a friend
Luigi Witcher teeny Luigi Witcher Dini
we can guess from Nikolas answer must
have written him a letter that's all you
know Nicola
last night a method gorgeous so charming
and we did this and that and he must
have gone forever and he must certainly
have ended the letter V G by say I can't
wait to see her again
Nikola what does it do he turns upside
down the letter of which he says I
instead I've met the most ugly woman on
earth I had the most horrible sexual
experience I ever had and I I'm sure
that for a long time
I will not see her again and for sure I
will not even look for other similar
experience it's the opposite of what we
did which our Dean was glorifying
himself nicola debases himself to have
fun
what about his marriage his love life
his relationship with women now you
bring me into very difficult a terrain
like a valley was we have only one
letter from his wife murrieta we have
letters of friends that speak of his
wife we have two letters from his
younger son Guido in which Guido speaks
of mother
what we can derive these little
evidences is that Murrieta crostini was
very fond of Nicola she missed him badly
when did they marry if I remember
correctly he must have married her soon
after and that of the father I guess
15:01 15 how old were they well we don't
know Murrieta
but Nicola at the time must have been
around 31 32 where did he meet her while
they were belonging to they both belong
it to feminists that Florentine families
of the same social ranking megive le
could not have married niccolò
machiavelli could not have married a
woman of the nobility and murrieta car
scene II could not have married a
prominent our aristocrats as you know at
the time marriages were a political and
economic affair was essential for a rich
father to marry their daughters way to
someone at least as powerful or as
wealthy so he's not surprising that was
my Nikola must've thought about getting
married after the death of his father
because I'm sure we call all dislike it
loneliness and solitude and and he
wanted to be surrounded by a family they
had seven children he was affectionate
Nicola you can see that because Marietta
says when you are here we feel safe it's
better when you are not with us and said
I'm disconsolate and she was angry at
him because he was spending so much time
abroad for diplomatic missions
Nikola was also a good father a
wonderful father and he's a wonderful
father I mean a father who was not
imposing not authoritarian he was too
poor and too powerless to be
authoritarian but we have a 1 we have
two letters from niccolò machiavelli to
his son widow that are really
spectacular the best I think of the
entire collection of Nikolas personal
letters you can see that Nicola was
teaching his son how to be a good person
how to try to attain great things by
working by studied and the way in which
he teaches his tender is affectionate
doesn't say you must he says if you do
that if you believe in yourself you will
attain in life probably great things
more than I've done and he tells Guido
he teaches some with a wonderful story
about weak creatures the story of the
little mule widow says well we have here
in the farm a mule that has become crazy
mad and what you normally do with crazy
mules is to kill them or to tie them up
Nicola says to the son don't do that let
him free bring him somewhere where he
can be free freedom we probably help the
little animal to regain his sanity it's
a wonderful story on the first story
having said all that I must immediately
emphasize Machiavelli
was not a lawyer husband not at all
he loved Murrieta crostini was not the
greatest love of his life
he was too fascinated by women's beauty
and he pursued it with great devotion
some success if we judge from the
records that we have until he was quite
old for his time till he was 54 his last
love let me know
the most dramatic because he fell in
love with a younger woman very
attractive
miss Barbara or Barbara an opera singer
and Niccolo
sadly remarks that if you fall in love
with a woman who is very attractive much
younger than you is likely that you
suffer bit because as you wrote in a
nice poem little poem so much beauty
deserves much younger person
with women but I found extraordinary is
that the common opinion sustained by
important scholars that Nicola was a
macho is completely absurd completely
I've seen I've shown in the book that in
important occasions he treats women as
equals that's not the behavior of a
matter he says that he has found in
women more tenderness more gratitude
deeper compassion and friendship more
lasting friendship than in men he says
that women are better than men even in
governing kingdoms and what impressed me
in reading this side of Nicholas life is
that he felt for women a kind he felt he
was similar to women in one sense that
like women in 16th century Florentine
society he was not part of the
privileged circle and all the stories I
have have rediscovered about his love
affairs they show us in Machiavelli that
Michael who is a poet as a poetic
abandonment about love how many love
affairs were you able to identify
the record speaks we one woman who was
waiting for him nearby pond Telegraph
see certainly one when he was in France
Yan or Jana then the best the most
lasting story with Lucrezia SEC detta
Morita the curly Curtis then probably
the wife of inferna Chaya
then for sure Barbara and in how many
others did he have any children violin
his woman no and did his wife know about
these women I asked myself the same
question I think that was difficult for
her to know but I cannot answer the
question that I think is even more
difficult namely as she known what was
would have been what would have been her
reaction how did all this go down in a
Catholic country back then oh precisely
in a Catholic counties the right country
where you can have affairs one because
there is the double morality because
there is the Pope and remember that
Pope's at time well the most liberty
creatures on earth read the letter in
which the Torah speaks describes a Tory
was in Rome with the Ambassador the
papal court he describes how he spends
his evenings and he says around 8
o'clock some women come to spend the
evening with us only to chat he says
because I'm too old too much else
they're coming from the court of the
Pope they've completed their day of
service and now they stopped by
graciously the friars there were famous
for being Libertines consider the story
that Machiavelli says puts in the mouth
of a character in one of his comedies
CLE Thea there is a woman speaking of
another woman and she says well she
wanted to be pregnant they told her that
if she goes for 40 days in a row to take
the first mass in the morning in the
fryer in difference in the convent in
the monastery she will certainly get the
miracle of getting pregnant and the
other woman said it would be a miracle
if she did not get pregnant by after
going for 40 days to take mass Catholic
countries are countries in which
transgression is much easier much easier
certainly Nicola had no moral anxieties
about his devotion to women's beauty in
consider one last aspect that Flores was
Catholic but also it was this vein of
paganism that is the same mentality
focused on the pursuit of beauty
pleasure trans grace you why and this is
my dog yard copy from many years ago in
college
why has this survived all these years
400 years and is read in this country
still by a lot of people in college high
school
it is certainly
it is discussed it is translated there
are new translations coming out every
year why I think because in that text
niccolò machiavelli tells us reveals to
us some important truths about political
life truths that surpass that go beyond
his own time his own intellectual
context of his time of course in the
Prince Machiavelli meant to teach
something to the political leaders of
his own time but certainly he wanted to
teach something important about politics
to possible future princes interested in
becoming great princes is one thing I
want to make clear
Niccolo never Thoth never intended to
teach princes real or possible present
or future princes how to gain power he
wanted to teach them how to do great
things in politics such as redeeming a
country liberating the people restoring
political life emancipating a republic
from corruption there was not a teacher
of ordinary law mediocre mean miserable
politics he was a teacher of grand
politics that is I think is the lasting
beauty of that text then you've been in
this country around 15 years 1313 of all
the politicians you've seen in the
United States would you call any of the
Machiavelli it's a difficult question
you know that in my courses I teach
course in political theory
I never comment about the United States
because I'm a resident alien and I think
it is indelicate for me to comment about
the life of a country to which I cannot
contribute since I'm not an American
citizen but I can certainly answer your
questions by saying that if you mean to
know what the meaning of your question
is you think there are politicians that
are Machiavellian the answer is easy
please plenty of politicians who are
simulators people will whom you cannot
trust people who are always prepared to
seek their own advantage all the
advantage of their faction and to put
the interest of their group above the
common interest of the Republic there
are plenty of them but if you asked me
have you ever seen in America or do you
know off from American history political
leaders whom like yearly would have
admired Buddha said he is a great
politician then the answer is yes
Machiavelli loved founders and Redeemers
those who have founded new states or
those who have redeemed republics from
corruption from slavery from oppression
you had plenty
Machiavelli like leaders were table
inspiring of touching people's passions
of generating a culture
of sustaining hope you had politicians
like that you had people like Roosevelt
had people like link you had people like
Martin Luther King please we're
certainly politicians that Meharry would
have enjoyed to meet and I'm sure that
they would have enjoyed the company of
niccolo how big was he slim tall
reasonably tall but slim it's a guess
because we ever yes we had a letter of
his wife in which his wife describes him
the baby that she just she had just had
and she say he looks like you so we know
that he had dark eyes that he was limb
and also because he was slim he survived
the torture in when he was tortured in
1513 when he was accused of a conspiracy
against the Medici he was tortured and
the torture was the torture of the Rope
people were hanged to the ceiling tied
to their back put the arms behind her
back and rope was tied and then they let
the rope and they went and that was the
torture and he stood by because he was
leave me here what were the
circumstances that he found himself in
that position because they found a note
who's they the prosecutors of the Medici
regime they discovered a note in the
pocket of one of the conspirators that
they captured and there was a list of
names 18 names and one of the names was
the name on the name of niccolo
machiavelli
so the prosecutors prosecutors were
people loyal to the Medici
imply that niccolò machiavelli was part
of the conspiracy
so they seized him they put him in jail
and they tortured in order to obtain the
confession because the legal system at
the time was based on the confession was
not a based on evidence how long was he
in jail from January I is easy through
March 10 he was about your 15 13 because
he was liberated thanks to the amnesty
because a member of the Medici family
became Pope with the name of Leo 10 so
there was great they were great
festivities in Florence and they'd and
of course the election of the Medici
Pope meant that the regime of the Medici
in Florence felt to be much safer
therefore it could afford was he
religious that's an it that's a question
that on which tons of hink have been
that with tons of ink as we have been
used in not to try to answer some
scholars maintain that he will had the
religiosity of his own not Catholic he
disliked the Roman Church he despised
Christianity
the ethos of Christianity he writes in
the discourses on Livy his major work he
says that Christianity has the great
responsibility of having made the world
weak because Chris Christian religion
teaches human beings to be humble to
suffer that there is dignity suffering
that their sufferance would be reward in
the afterlife
I don't think Nikola was religious in as
a Christian or as a Catholic
did he entertain a Christian or
religious hope for salvation my answer
is that he didn't in fact if there is
one figure one name that is remarkably
absent from his works and from his that
is Jesus can you be a Christian without
taking Jesus the figure of Jesus very
Deemer the Savior see I think that he
never became religious not even in his
last years and they here I enter in a
very difficult terrain because there are
scholars who have claimed that Nicola in
at the end of his life had the moral and
religious crisis he became religious I
think on the counted on the contrary
that certainly until 1521 it is to say
six years before his death he showed no
sign of religious conversion we have
evidences that he was still Nicola the
Reverend the anti Christian and the
evidence is a letter from a man who knew
Nicola very well
the intelligent stilt cold powerful
creature Dini
Francesca Whichard in one of the
greatest eternal political thinkers of
the time and which our dana says now
that you are in carpi he was involved in
a strange mission in a monastery having
to do with monks all day which i Dini
says be careful not to become devout
because you are dealing everyday with
monks because since you have lived all
your life as a non-religious person if
you now become if you now convert
yourself you become a devout people will
say that your conversion is not the
result of the fact that your good is the
result of your senility people who think
that he hands senile and what he did in
carpi to the monks shows that he was not
very keen to become religious in fact he
spent most of his time
plotting jokes against the monks
hilarious jokes pranks then we have the
story of Nikolas dream friends
it's a story there are some evidences
but not compelling evidences that on his
deathbed Machiavelli described the dream
that he had and in the moral of the
dream was that Machiavelli openly said
to his friends that when he said when I
die I don't want to go to paradise I
want to go to hell
because is much more interesting place
and inhale I can talk to the great
people on tickety the people he loved my
last remark on your question was he
religious is the following
I think Nicola did not believe in God
though he spoke a lot about God from a
political point of view because Nicola
did not need God in order to attain kind
of transcendence infinity for him great
pages thinking about grand political
ideas composing books that would last
was his way of attaining glory and glory
means that you survive time he didn't
need God do you teach Machiavelli at
Princeton I do I do
what are your students think of him
teaching at Princeton has been for me
spectacular experience spectacular
experience what students in the I teach
large courses courses like political
theory this year I have about 300
students what do they say about
Machiavelli some of them say no
professor we're all you're wrong you
know that American students they do not
hesitate to question the professor which
would be scandal by Italian standards
some say no professor we're only
Machiavelli is a teacher of evil he is
immoral but others say Nicola deserves
admiration because he was courageous he
said with the other political theorists
did not want to say about politics
he hasn't covered to us the real meaning
of political action both the greatness
of politics and the harbor's of politics
in any case Machiavelli has showed us
with um beveling the ambivalent
greatness of politics in bed terms in
good terms so I get as you would say
mixed comments from the students
Machiavelli worked for a government how
often how long how many years how many
different princes niccolò machiavelli
served as a secretary of the Republic of
Florence from 1498 through November 1512
it is about 15 years then he was
dismissed when a new regime replaced the
regime controlled by the family of the
Medici replaced the Republic for which
Machiavelli was working Mercury never
had the direct political power he was an
advisor he his job was to say go to
France or to Rome and meet the King of
France or meet the Pope and report back
in writing so when people say
Machiavelli was a politician it's not
correct he was he could not make a
single decision other other leaders
other committees were deciding on the
basis of his letters but he had no
political power whatsoever
then from 1512 until very late until
1525 he was in disgrace
he had no relevant political
positions I'll make money he had he was
penniless in order to make money while
he was living out of his possessions he
had some land south of Florence in Sant
Andreu cocina some land so he had wood
the products of the head chicken he was
he says in a letter in the evening when
I sit with my family with little that we
can afford or he's likely to see his
family our letters that and with the
recommendation tried to spend as little
as possible do you have a family of your
own yeah I ever
I live with a companion in Italy
children no I do not have children on my
own how much time do you spend in Italy
how much time the United States I spend
a lot of time in Italy because I'm
involved in some kind of civic
activities because I think that the duty
of the scholar is not simply scholar who
studies political theory it is not
simply to write books and to teach but
also to be active by being active I mean
taking position on political and moral
issues in my case on political and moral
issues in Italy speaking up trying to
criticize do you belong to a party in
Italy no I don't belong to a party I
belong to cultural association that
dates back to the old days of the
Risorgimento
is a secular liberal Association small
prestigious not powerful what do we do
our goal has always been to try to keep
alive a civic culture by civic culture
and mean a culture or a mode of life
based on the idea that to be a citizen
does not simply mean to have rights but
also to have duties responsibilities
doesn't simply be a citizen does not
simply mean that they owe something to
you it also means that if you want to
remain free if you want to live in a
decent society you have to be prepared
to give something give your intelligence
your time your strength your courage and
in order to do that they go to Italy I
write for a newspaper I'm a columnist
which one last Tampa of Turin you say
your communist don't know it columnist
I'm sorry
because chimeras are active in Italy
aren't they where they were and I too
was a member of the Communist Party this
is that's a funny story
I think oh another time I might reveal
it we are about out of time but I want
to ask you to dedicate this book to the
former mayor of Raveena Raavan Ravenna
and who is the mayor and when did he
live the mayor of Ravenna was my great
friend Pierre Paulo the Torah he was a
few years older than me he died some
years ago he was a brilliant historian
and at a certain time in his life he
decided to become the mayor of his own
City Robin on
Adriatic coast and for me Pierpaolo the
Torah remains the example of a person
who entered in politics in order to do
some good to his own City to his own
people to build the city that is
beautiful because it is just that is
pleasant because it's dignified and it
is dignified because it's a city that
takes care of all of those who are weak
people the Torah in my mind my judgment
is the best example of what a democratic
politician should be here's the cover of
the book it's called Niccolo smile
Mauricio parolee has been our guest
thank you very much thank you